so I don't I don't like the idea of me
getting laid and then suddenly like well
who cares about theater
who cares about SNL or my Creator be
inside of another human being on a
Saturday night why am I why am I
worshiping both for the love oh my God
no you just went full Farley I did now
here's what I want to tell you just let
the boy sleep in your bed he's a good
boy he said he'd wash the sheets please
don't make me wash the teeth wash your
own damn sheets but you're missing the
best part when he does those Impressions
yeah
yeah he's a good boy will you let him
watch
it's like throwing salt on a chocolate
chip cookie man it Farley would do stuff
like that nobody's funnier nobody has
ever made me laugh that hard and he I
thought he was a really good actor he
could have done a lot of other things
like that moment in Tommy Boy in the
boat I was like yeah I mean just being
vulnerable and I've told the story I'm
not gonna tell you but I'll tell you as
you know as buddies all the time but
like I uh I had I I hung out with him a
few times I was like Kevin his brother
asked me to be in the documentary I told
the story of the first time I met him
and it was just oh that's right I saw
you in the document it was I am Chris
Farley yeah I think it was I am
Christian yeah yeah but anyway yeah I I
I had Bob Odenkirk on here who wrote All
the I know uh you know those sketches uh
Matt Foley Bob's the one who's very
vehemently against the um Chippendale
sketch he's very yeah he said it on here
he was just like yeah I didn't like how
you know it was just
um fatty fall down yeah yeah
if we're we're closing out let's talk
Farley for a few minutes right talk
Farley all right so yeah so I met him uh
his brothers were on this show it was
the worst ranked show in history it was
like ranked 130 out of 131 oh well 129.
and uh it was terrible it was it was a
Tom Arnold show love Tom the show was
terrible it was me Ed McMahon but I had
like I was like six you know Tom was
Chris's sponsor yes yeah uh love Tom I'm
his son's Godfather and but the show was
just bad but we had a lot of fun and so
I'm doing a scene and I'm saying my
lines and people are starting to really
laugh and I'm like my lines aren't funny
there I don't know why they're they
can't it can't be at me
and I turn and Farley wall is is there
he's in a suit baggy suit and he just
kind of swayed into the eye she's like
oh three camera yeah yeah four camera I
think and he goes he goes how are you
all right how are you good to see you
good all right now looks good on you and
and so good yeah good all right
and I'm
numb and I go I have to do something
that he'll remember me but I I just half
this is my hero and I go
hey everybody
look it's the big fat guy taking all the
attention away from the skinny Punk
who's trying to have a career and he go
looks at me and goes there's it and he
runs over he picks me up over his
shoulder starts smacking my ass runs
through the studio everybody's smacking
my ass we go in the golf cart afterwards
up through Universal the psycho house we
have beers I go back to his house to
have some drinks what was this 95 96
seven or something oh that was right
before right before because I remember
this the horrible part is his brothers
we came in for a moment with Tom Arnold
he had a a in his an egg meeting in his
dressing room and he says get in here I
go I don't really have a drink get the
[__] in here you're coming in here come
on buddy get in here it is me Johnny and
Kevin Farley and I remember Kevin just
going
you know Tom looks at him we're talking
he goes Buddy hey your brother's he's
gonna die you know your brothers can you
just can't I can't maintain that yeah
and Kevin's like yeah I know and
Johnny's just like they're distraught
they're like you know we don't know what
to do
and then I feel like it wasn't long it
might have been a week or two it seems
like less
that all of a sudden
Kevin starts running across the stage
and I'm sitting on the couch waiting
just looking at my lines or taking a nap
or so I see him I know Kevin are you all
right he looked frantic he goes my
brother just died
and
everybody was just like what just
I still I just feel it right now I feel
that moment
heartbroken heartbroken for them and
heartbroken for Chris and heartbroken
for so many people that just loved him
just people felt like they knew him you
know he just made everybody feel good
and made everybody laugh and it was just
it was it was
you know I went from a great moment to a
tragic moment but I remember I'll never
forget when Kevin ran off stage it was I
don't really tell that have I told that
story never told that story yeah it was
it was heartbreaking heartbreaking
I I think um
I I think there is something
you can there's some stuff you can teach
with comedy you can teach some comedy
you know uh you watch Rose Byrne in
Bridesmaids and it's like she's being
very funny but she has to be a different
kind of funny you know opposite all
these crazy women
the characters I mean
um and then there's comedy you can't
teach there's something
that's in your blood and your bones that
is
almost like a nationality
does that make sense yep I think Chris
had some
nationality of Comedy that uh you know I
believe in God everybody else you know
says you've shown your blank here but I
really believe that God gave Chris like
the nationality of Comedy
and he was always destined to use that
to bring light into the world but you
know if I believe in God you know I I
believe in the other guy I believe in
the other side of it and I think
there's something that that really
Darkness loves Darkness Darkness and
liquid
and Chris Chris got extinguished too
early
um
and it's awful it's absolutely yeah
awful because
um
because he there was so much more
waiting for Chris there was there was a
wife there were kids there were
Academy Award nominatable uh
opportunities there were non-profits
there were all these things that were
there the sky was the limit